all right
I will go ahead and get started
um so thanks for the introduction
um I'm Lily from recidivist I am a tech
lead manager at recidiviz I've been here
for about a year and a half
um and yeah I'll be giving
um a short-ish overview of the
organization
um and I'll pause for some q a
um if there's any and then I will pass
it over to Genevieve who will go into a
much more detailed technical dive so if
you have questions about that you can
save it for her
um
all right so recidivas is a non-profit
organization with the mission of
reducing incarceration across the
country
we are a very Tech focused non-profit
um about half of our employees our
engineers
um and the very high level way in which
we work is that we partner with State
Corrections agencies we ingest their
data and then we use that data to run
analyzes and build tools and products
that influence their policy practices
and behaviors in a reform-minded and
decarceral way
Mr Davis was founded about four years
ago currently we have a team of over 60
people we grew a lot during covid and
then even more since covid
um we're a very remote organizations for
not all across the country but with
small offices
um in both Oakland and New York City
and we are currently partnered with
correct Corrections agencies in 11
states which account for over a fourth
of the U.S prison population and we are
always working on expanding that number
and forming Partnerships with with more
and more States
so what's really great about our working
model is that it is non-partisan we
partner with both red and blue States
and there are several reasons why States
all across the Spectrum sign up to work
with us
and especially why they do so right now
um so one is Staffing shortages
Corrections agencies are having a lot of
trouble hiring people currently so a lot
of agencies are looking to safely reduce
their prison populations to a size that
can be effectively managed by a smaller
number of Staff while they attempt to to
kind of hire and fill for those vacant
positions
another is that we're currently in a
tough climate for Criminal Justice
Reform legislation there's a real um
popularity of the talk on crime
narrative these days
um and so states that might have
previously focused on getting new
policies passed to affect change now
have to seek other Alternatives and the
way we work our process doesn't require
new legislation instead what we do is
ensure that we're making the most of
existing legislation and really like
maximizing out the change that we can
affect under those policies
so what is our process exactly
there are three main components
and I will go into these more in detail
shortly but at a very high level
the first part is identifying people who
are stuck in the system people maybe who
are eligible for release entirely or who
are eligible for a lower level of
custody or supervision and then helping
them get unstuck and moved through
another is identifying staff and
officers who have demonstrated overly
carceral behavior and working to shift
their behavior
um to
um in a more reform-minded way
and then lastly holding agencies
accountable to their data and their
results by making all of that public
um and being able to track Trends and
changes over time
one thing to clarify before moving
forward is that currently as might have
been clear from the previous slides we
focus our work on the what we call the
back half of the criminal justice system
so that's namely prisons and Community
Supervision so people who are on Pro
parole of probation after getting out of
prison
um and there are definitely levers to be
pulled earlier on in this in in the
system like reducing the number of
people who get arrested or sentenced to
prison in the first place
um and we hope to expand into these
areas in the future but are are not
currently doing as much in there
um so you hear me talking a lot about
prison and Community revision that's
because that's that's really what our
bread and butter is right now
okay so now I can dive in a little more
detail into that three-step process I
mentioned
so this first component is identifying
people
who are succeeding but who are stuck so
this might be someone who is eligible
for release from prison but their
officer hasn't had the time to fill out
the paperwork to get them released
um which is a shockingly common
occurrence and I think was one of the
most surprising things to me when I
joined recidivist is that this is even a
thing that someone could be in prison
for way longer than they have to just
because they don't maybe even know that
they're eligible and their officer is
overworked and they're just kind of
lingering there
um or it might mean someone who maybe
isn't eligible for a full release but is
eligible for like I said a lower level
of cussy or supervision that would
require you know that would make their
life a little bit easy a little bit
easier and get them closer to Liberty
so we use our data to find these people
and then we surface these people to the
officers and staff who can actually take
the right actions and even more than
that we try to automate as much of the
process as possible
um so this can mean actually going ahead
and filling out the forms and the
paperwork for that overworked officer so
that they don't have to do you know they
have to do as little as possible all
they have to do is press a button and
the paperwork is sent off to the right
person and the first person is moved out
of the system
um because basically you know a lot of
these these staff and officers are like
I said really overworked there are major
Staffing shortages and they're not
incentivized to get people moved out of
the system as quickly as possible but if
we make it really easy for them they
will
it also might mean highlighting people
who are not yet eligible for release or
for an opportunity
um but who are almost eligible
and they just need a pointer to a few
remaining steps they can take a program
they need to enroll in a test they need
to pass
um
a certain number of days they need to go
without
um a certain violation Etc and so we can
Surface these things that they still
need to do and create a checklist for
them and their parole or probation
officer or a staff officer to to work
through together
so these are a lot of the web and
product tools that we build are um are
basically for this first component which
is getting people out of the system
um identifying them surfacing them
automating the steps to to get them
moved out
the second component is a little more
heavy on the data analysis side
um and this is to look at people the
staff and the officers who are meeting
with the incarcerated individuals or
individuals in supervision and are
making the decisions that control how
quickly these folks move through the
system they have these officers have a
lot of power
um
and we've found from looking at the data
that some are way more punitive and
carceral than others
um however with intervention having
conversations with them surfacing this
to them they might not even know that's
the case because they're not talking to
their peers and getting a sense of you
know what everyone else how everyone
else is calibrating right so by talking
to them they might realize oh I didn't
know that I was being a little more
harsh than I should be or that that my
peers are and we can really shift their
behavior
and finally the third component is to
create accountability and this is by you
know once we've done a lot of this work
to to affect change we want to make that
change stick we want to make sure that
you know even one reason of his lessons
our involvement with a state or with an
agency they continue to keep up the work
that we've set them up for and so one
way to do this is to have them
um is to to make as much of their data
and results public so that um Advocates
and policy makers and protective
practitioners can see the trends can see
the data can see the story over time of
which states which agencies are having
which results you know which policies
which practices are working which ones
aren't working and then can kind of put
pressure on States and agencies to to
change or to you know to say hey this
this was really working super well in
Arkansas maybe you should try it in
Nebraska or or so forth
um so the Justice counts and the
spotlight projects mentioned on this
slide both work their mission is to make
data accessible to the public
the spark project mentioned here is a
little bit different
um what that project does is to use the
public data that we collect to actually
create memos that advocate for or
against certain legislation that is up
to be passed and so we kind of to go a
step further we take this public data
and we use it to model the effect that
we think a certain piece of legislation
is going to have on the prison
population on disparities on on equity
in the future and so we use some machine
learning and modeling here to make those
predictions and then to bring in an info
in in bring it to policymakers to help
them make their decision about the
legislation
Okay so
how do we accomplish all this I mean I
mentioned this earlier we we partner
with States so our kind of business
model or working model is that our
client is the state and so we go and
form Partnerships with States
they enter into Data sharing agreements
with us where they agree to send us
their
um the individual person level data on
everybody in in the system in that state
you know their names where they
currently are what their release date is
what you know it's a huge huge amounts
of data which Genevieve will get into
soon
um and then in return we offer them data
science and product services so we do
analyzes for them we build products for
them we build tools for them
um and we sort of act
um in this kind of reciprocal way
um so yeah so like I said we're getting
in huge amounts of case level data
coming in every day from these states
um and of course or maybe not of course
but um what is very true is that every
state deals with different data in
different formats right there isn't like
a Country-Wide you know standard for
this is how you handle your case level
data every state has a different schema
different types of data they collect
different names for those columns you
know you name it it's different
um and so what our data platform does is
automatically import Injustice this raw
data normalize it convert it to a common
schema and then use it to power the
analyzes and tools and products that we
build so that we're able to just build a
tool once right you know a single piece
of code for a tool and have it work
across all of the states we partner with
kind of magically because our platform
has done that standardization and
normalization
um and I will not talk any more about
this because a I don't really know how
it works because I don't work in this
part of the organization and Genevieve
is the expert and she will go into much
more depth very soon
um but that's the segue to her part um
before that any questions on the high
level overview of recidiv is
um happy to to answer anything
um yeah
go ahead
um my first question was
um after you after you finish with the
prison population
um are you going to be able to or has
anybody proposed tackling the the jail
population uh there's been a recent
ruling by a fairly high level judge I
think it was California that said yeah
if you haven't if you haven't brought
somebody in front of a judge or
magistrate within 10 days you've got to
let them go
um it could be it could have been a
different state but there's a lot of
people languishing in jail awaiting for
just a hearing
and
just just wondered if that that was
going to be in recidivism's future
absolutely that's a great question
um you know I'm not I'm not 100 sure of
the answer I think part of the reason we
haven't I mean I'm sure we would love to
and I think it almost certainly is on a
road map I think part of what makes that
challenging is unlike um and Jennifer I
see you come on videos if you asked me
to add to this but I think unlike
um Corrections jail data is often not as
centralized in a state and like it's
more local so that's like jail data is
often handled by the law enforcement
agencies in a city or in a county so
it's not as simple as partnering with
this you know the corrections agency and
getting all that data in one Fell Swoop
it would require forming relationships
with all of these different law
enforcement agencies and they might all
be formatting their data differently so
it kind of exponentially increases the
problem of doing that standardization
um I'll let you time in if you have
anything else
nope that's perfect I was just gonna say
pretty much the same thing I think
nothing really off the table in terms of
what we are interested in doing
especially as it could have increasingly
important impact
um but we are a little bit at the mercy
of what we actually can get data on and
so I think
um over time we're increasingly
interested in identifying Partnerships
with states that are specifically
interested in addressing jail
populations Etc up to this point we
haven't necessarily focused on it but it
is certainly a interesting opportunity
in the future
somebody else had a question
yes I had a question
um so I I did notice that and maybe I
just missed this but um it didn't look
like North Carolina was on that list of
states
um as far as sort of um the process
involved in onboarding a state is that
something that will be covered later in
this talk or
um so I guess if we're going to talk
about North Carolina specifically
um is that a is that an issue of getting
our hands on the data what what is the
specific limitation in you know the
example of North Carolina that would
prevent you all from from being able to
add them to your list
yeah
um that's a great question so I don't
think that will be covered later on I
think the um
we I don't have a ton of insight into
exactly the process of partnering with
the new state we have staff at recidivas
whose entire job is to form
relationships with people in different
states and negotiate with them about
what a partnership might look like
um and some states are really excited
and eager to sign up right away others
have hesitations for one reason or
another
um I mean it costs money to partner with
us right so it's not something that we
we don't provide the services for free
even though we often do subsidize them
with other grants and funding so that we
can make it as cheap as possible for
States
um and we try to make us that very
little work is required on the state's
part really it's pretty simple to set up
that data pipeline where you start
sending the data to us but um but yeah
there's negotiation and agreement to be
had in terms of whether the partnership
is right for the state whether it's
whether we can provide services that
they're looking for to make it worth
their time you know sometimes the states
have their certain states have really
technically sophisticated departments
already that are like we do all of our
data analysis in-house and we don't need
you know any more tools but thank you
right so it kind of depends and I don't
I don't know about North Carolina's
position
um in particular
thank you yeah um I sorry can I ask one
more question very quick question
um so I I was also curious because um
and I know this is kind of a tough
subject and maybe you all don't
necessarily want to address this over uh
the video but
um maybe offline but um you know I know
that some states uh you know have the
death penalty
um is that is that something is that a
maybe an area that you all have looked
into
um as far as you know using the data for
you know a positive goal
um in that space
um with with the states that you are uh
partnered with
yeah that's a great question
um
probably where that would have come up
and I'm not sure if it has but would
have been with the spark policy memos I
mentioned yes that's what I I thought
about yeah yeah it's not something we'd
probably bring up
with like States as part of our normal
Partnerships I think with those
Partnerships we try to be like I said
kind of a little bit more nonpartisan
um and meet them where they're at
our spark policy memos I think we have
tended to take more of a stance on
certain issues I know we've done
legislation regarding like marijuana
legalization and stuff like that I don't
know about my head know if we've had one
on death penalty I wouldn't be surprised
if we had
um but it it kind of depends on you know
um What legislation is up at what time
and what data we have and whether we can
make a you know whether we can model
something that we think would make a
compelling case and whether we think we
have a chance that you know so there's a
lot of factors in terms of what we what
we do or do not choose to do yeah sure
yeah and that would make sense too
especially from like the data
perspective because
um you know it's my understanding as far
as the death penalty specifically
um you know the overall cost associated
with you know putting someone on death
row and then carrying out that whole
process
um you know I the extent to which all of
that is being captured and updated and
maintained
um you know I'm sure that's you know
wildly very able from state to state so
so yeah
thank you thank you so much yeah
oh okay I had muted myself uh have you
run up against the automated sentencing
software that judges use
oh
um
maybe so we're actually just beginning
to Branch out into it's like music like
I mentioned you know we've mostly
focused on the back half of the pipeline
so it's after someone's already in
prison
um we're spitting up a work stream like
I think literally today someone joined
to lead that team
um so I I think I know a little bit
about this but maybe not not a ton it's
quite possible you know a lot more than
me too early okay uh I wanted to tell
everyone that I had invited the Wilson
Center this is a Duke
law school law and social science law
and science that's it the the Wilson
Center at Duke is a law and science uh
organization uh to give a presentation
about the work that they did that they
did would probably not be very technical
but certainly would meet the theme of
let's we've got a big problem in America
what can we do about it
thank you
oh sorry but but they didn't have it
they couldn't come up with a speaker
yeah it's uh to your point very much uh
lots of discussion going on and there's
ongoing efforts to do that we have done
various specific analyzes around their
sentencing policy so Blanko stay
analysis and things of that nature
um truth and sentencing we've done some
analyzes on so all that to say that it
is certainly something that we are
interested in and I guess broadly sorry
fire truck going by I don't know if you
can hear it
[Music]
um
broadly we're interested in any sort of
opportunity that could highlight certain
discrepancies or certain ways in which
policies are not actually serving the
population we are Intercultural
organization so we are interested in
things like that but it is ultimately
something that
um I think we are excited about the
future opportunities to develop
in partnership with others as well as
within you know internally sentencing
calculators understanding length of say
things like that so very much an
exciting New Frontier that we're excited
to get into
Mark I wanted to let you know your mic
is picking up some sort of metallic
clicking noise and it's coming up sorry
sorry it's it's a fidget it's a fidget
thing sorry that's what I'll take my
hand away from the the little metal
thing that I'm fidgeting with
a binder clip
uh there aren't any other questions
should we turn over to Genevieve in the
second half of the show
well let me let me at least show up
very sure thanks Mark okay
this uh it appears Genevieve's got her
hair pulled pulled back all the way so
she is going to look a little she is
going to look a little different but and
Genevieve uh now that we've heard about
the uh
uh the who is the who of recidiv is and
their mission statement the how
of recidiv is uh
is Genevieve and I'm going to give it a
shot first ever heide Camp did I get
that right correct I can't yay
give me a second I did not take I did
not take German Inc in school
all right can you all see my screens
stop sharing
no I gotta stop sharing first
data to recidivist products a very
overarching hopefully inspiring message
for you all
um
so yes today
um Lily did an amazing job of kind of
talking about what we try to do
aristidov is and a very natural question
that we get asked very often and I
actually don't know specifically all of
your backgrounds but um especially if
someone has worked in the government or
with government agencies government data
is interesting to work with to say the
least and so um a huge portion of our
work and the development of our data
platform
[Music]
um apologies so a huge part of our work
is how do we identify the data that we
need within State databases and then get
it into the recidivist system clean it
do a bunch of things with it so that we
can fuel products and analyzes and
things like that
um
so this is the highest level of a
visualization of what we try to do when
we talk about State data we're talking
about typically
I mean some of these are mainframes from
the 1980s 200 different tables with many
different pieces of information and one
of the really important things that Lily
pointed out um previously was that for
example there could be one policy that's
early discharge and there's 10
requirements that someone has to meet
for that but that lives in 10 different
tables in 10 different places in the
state data system and So currently one
of the big issues is that
um you know a parole officer is going to
have to check 10 different places in
order to fill out a form to then get
that person early discharged so as you
can imagine that takes really long time
and so our goal is to create a
standardized data layer that then makes
all of that chaotic many different
threads of many different things into
four beautifully straight curves lines
which honestly even then sometimes it's
not but we do try our best to clean it
up as much as possible
um this somewhat confusing diagram this
uh one of the ones that Lily showed at
the end is in the highest level version
what we mean when we refer to the data
platform at recidivist so we import the
data from the state we ingest it which
ingests is what I'm really going to go
into more detail on of like what do we
mean when we say ingest and then once
that data is cleaned and in a much
prettier State agnostic format we then
use that data to calculate things things
like count of admission metrics on
certain days things like
um most severe violation types over a
certain amount of time
um and then all of that
analysis and count Etc will be fueled
and exported out to um various different
products and analyzes that we've talked
about up to this point
so
um
specifically the platforms that we're
using
um again I mentioned kind of import
ingest calculate
um we use Google cloud services for
almost everything
um with a few exceptions and so the
ingest process happens within um you
know our raw data gets drum just gets
dropped into Google cloud services
storage then we put it into bigquery
bigquery is where we do a bunch of our
analyzes and then eventually into
dataflow is where we actually calculate
all of these various different things so
we'll calculate things like admissions
we'll calculate things like
incarceration starts incarceration
finishes things of that nature
one caveat to all of this is at any
point you probably could be thinking
like you're saying a lot of acronyms or
confusing things which I have tried to
make it as not uh vocab specific as
possible but uh some specific
definitions that are helpful when I
refer to Raw data that means the files
that we receive from States so States
will send us read-only CSV versions of
the data that lives in their system that
is the raw data which we then use and
within all of our pipelines
um gcp GCS bigquery data flow are all
Google platforms that we use to actually
do all of the processing that we do and
then schema which I will go specifically
into what our schema looks like is
essentially the state agnostic version
of how we envision criminal justice data
and the goal is to take raw data
do transformation on it to hydrate our
schema in a state agnostic way that says
across any person that we've received
information on in the criminal justice
system no matter what state they're from
we could give you a list of all of the
various periods of incarceration that
they've gone under so when they started
incarceration at first all of the
important status movements during that
time and then when they were eventually
released for example
um so ingest what do we mean by that
what are we actually saying ingest
translates to basically hydrating our
schema our state agnostic schema of how
we visualize criminal justice data
and
um this is the official definition of it
we at first obviously start with no data
uh we talked a little bit about you know
like how does our partnership start with
the state
um
we do basically have to we are at the
control of whether a state is willing to
work with us and is willing to send us
data or not
um and so there's a whole slew of work
related to business development that I
am not at all uh the right person to
talk to you about that
um I do know that we are always
interested in partnering with new state
so if in North Carolina for specifically
you have a con contact with the
Department of Corrections do let us know
because we are always happy to have the
chance to open up new potential
interactions but the partner States we
have currently are states that have
signed with us that have signed a DSA
with us that are willing to send us
their data to then fuel analyzes and
products for them so we don't have their
data at first they then send us the raw
data and then we try to convert that
into recidivas
um
percent of its data now one important
thing to call out is before ninjas can
actually begin we figure out who to talk
to in the state
um and we need to basically identify
which part of the system they are most
interested in beginning with some states
say we need a lot of help with our
supervision data or supervision system
and others will say actually our
incarceration population is more of an
issue so that will kind of direct which
data we ask for first
um we'll plan out kind of the first
couple things that we're going to work
on with them and then that's really when
I as an implementation engineer come in
and I will have to interact with the
whatever version of State I.T Department
exists in the state and say okay you
know the Department of Corrections is
looking for all the supervision
movements for people that have been
incarcer people that have been under
Supervision in the state and someone in
the state I.T department will tell me
okay that lives in these four tables and
I'll say great
can you send me those tables can you
give me a data dictionary for those
tables and can we make sure that the DSA
is signs so that we have a contract and
they're ready to start sending us data
now
that is a long process in one slide I've
just summarized what usually takes
months of time because there's many
discussions to be had along all those
things but once we have confirmed that a
state is interested in working with us
and is going to send us data we ask them
to do one of two things we need to
receive the data in an automated way
it's really important for fueling on
analyzes keeping them up to date making
sure that
um you know we could create an analysis
but if that data is months old they
could come to us and say oh the 10
people that you identified that were
eligible for this opportunity are no
longer eligible which really defeats the
purpose of us doing the analysis so we
do require in some capacity to receive
automated data there's two ways they can
do that they can either push the data
directly to us into a Google Cloud
Storage bucket and we can set them up
with credentials to do that or they have
an sfcp site that they will upload the
CSV files to and then we can pull the
data we have
um our platform has an automated way
that we can look for files anytime
they're new pull them down into our
Google system and then fuel
um the rest of the Pipelines
so excuse me the steps of ingest
assuming we are starting this journey
saying okay the state has already agreed
to send us data
they are ready to push the data into the
Google service bucket or it's going to
be an SFTP we're ready to get it now
let's actually do something with that
data we are going to try to ingest that
data make it as clean and beautiful as
possible so that our data analysts our
product team everyone that works at the
data Downstream can do so
um much more cleanly and with as little
headache as possible as you can imagine
there are times when
the way that a state thinks about
certain data doesn't really fit with our
our state agnostic schema but we have
ways to adapt to that which I'll go into
so the first step is the import step we
get those raw data files from the state
they send us first an initial historical
dump so they'll send us every single
um piece of information they have from
all time with most States they'll tell
you okay after
you can trust data after January 1st
1995 but all of the data before that
might be an issue because we changed our
data system in 1994 or because this
changed Etc and so there's usually some
sort of cut off but we do ask for any
data they have because it does help us
create a full picture of the supervision
or incarceration systems in the state
and transparently there are people that
are still incarcerated on supervision
today that were also incarcerated around
Supervision in 1995 so it's very
important to us that we do have as much
of that data as possible
um we also will ask for validation data
from the state can you what how do you
know what your incarceration population
is for example and so we can confirm
that and it is really a
siren filled uh day in my neighborhood I
apologize
um and so they start sending us that
data and we will configure our data with
um yaml files and with specific encoding
and separators to basically know that
we're going to receive the data in the
same way every time
um we do ask states to
pick the same encoding to pick a
separator that's not going to be used in
those CSV files we can basically hard
code any sort of decision they make so
if they're like oh we have to send it to
you with a double dagger delimiter great
we'll just put it into our system we can
handle many different encodings many
different separators the goal is
basically to make it as easy as possible
for them to send us their data so that
they are pleased and excited to work
with us they're like man recidivist we
can send it to them in this format and
they can use it and they're delighted to
answer all of our questions
because after we received these CSV
tables is when the real work of ingest
begins
before I get into exactly the platform
and how we use that I want to describe a
little bit what we mean when we say
State schema so our schema is our state
agnostic view of Criminal Justice data
that starts with the key entity being
the state person so that will include
information on someone's name their
identification number within the state
so their DOC number birthday gender race
ethnicity
um email address phone number current
address if we have it and then we start
to build and connect for that person
various different components of
different entities that relate to that
person
so for example we have a state person
entity in our schema we also have a
state incarceration period of within our
schema that's the incarceration period
the single unit of it is a single period
of incarceration so it would be someone
serves some type of incarceration in
this place under this custody level from
this date to this date and here's why
that is like one single unit
what we can then do
is we can build those incarceration
periods up over time so for one person
we can connect in our schema all of the
different incarceration periods they've
ever experienced so in this case we have
a person that had a single type of
incarceration from 2001 to 2010 and then
from 2010 to 2012 they were on
supervision and then in 2019 to now they
are incarcerated again so we have
incarceration periods we have
supervision periods we do have sentence
entities within our schema so we can
connect to a state person we can say
these are the incarceration sentences
they've received these are the
supervision sentences they've received
so on and so forth the goal being
that we are able to essentially paint a
picture
within our schema of all of the things
that have happened to someone during
their time with the Department of
Corrections so
for this person in particular
during the supervision period perhaps
they had some supervision violations
perhaps they were supervised by the
specific parole officer our schema will
know that we also will be able to tell
you all of this was related to a single
specific sentence from 2001 maybe or
something else who knows but the goal
being we ingest all of this separately
and then we stitch it together at the
end after we've cleaned it and confirmed
that it does match what the state thinks
is true for this person
Genevieve yes will you take questions
during your presentation or do we have
to wait till afterwards
a few questions during I can't see the
chat unless unless I pop
it not a problem
um when you got to the uh what you
received in raw data from the state
um I've I have encountered data from
Texas not prison data
that was it wasn't delimited it would
the data dictionary was was a Cobalt 77
section
with overlays and you know this this
field repeats in times and it's it's a
big mess and I'm wondering if you've if
you run into a state where
yeah
it's almost purposefully not friendly
not friendly to share or acquire data
the data is the way the state has it and
if you want to use it well you have to
jump through all of the Hoops to do the
processing because they're not going to
delimit it for you that kind of thing
have you run it have you run into that
not necessarily in Texas but that would
that was what comes to mind from uh
previous experience
yeah it's a great question
um
we are willing to work with the state
within reason
um and I think a lot of what I'm going
through here and our ability to import
transform and then put it into our
analyzes is based on the fact that we
know States
do not have the resources or time to
make things as pretty as possible for us
so we certainly have had interesting
situations where a state will say we the
way we think about our data is like this
and so we're going to send it to you
like this and then you have to figure
out how to like make that into periods
for example that does happen very often
if a state is unwilling excuse me to
send us delimited csvs it does very much
limit our ability to do any work
um like if they pretty much were like no
we're not going to send you our data
well that's
a choice that they're making that we
can't really like if they're not willing
to send us the data in some format that
we can interpret then we can't really do
much with it
um one of the reasons we do have the
flexibility on what type of encoding is
used or one separator is used is the
fact that we do want it to be as simple
as possible for them to send
um and so
um we also I will say it sometimes
people ask like oh well does the state
create a view of their database that
they send to you like we actually
request them not to do that we
specifically say do not send us a view
of your data send us the raw table
exactly as it is because
um when they build on logic of the views
there's sometimes like things that we
don't realize that they're doing that
then when we start analyzing it there's
things missing Etc so we do try to ask
for the most simplistic version of send
us the base raw data that we can use to
understand State person incarceration
movements Etc
um but that it has its bounds and the
fact that if a state literally said well
we won't send you csds at all then I
don't know how we would work with them
or
um
we've had to get creative I think on you
know perhaps that they said we'll send
you csvs but it's it's some kind of
crazy something we might be willing to
work with it or be able to use it within
our systems but there is constantly a
question of the amount of resources it
would take for us to build a
state-specific solution for interpreting
certain data that depending on how much
they're paying us to do that
um would influence how much how many
engineering resources we could actually
provide to create the engine that would
ingest their data differently than how
we get it from the rest of the states
um but transparently we aside from you
know some intricacies around what
delimiter or encoding or we're going to
send it to you on this schedule not this
schedule
States typically do not have an issue
sending us read-only versions of their
csvs that's not been something that
they've said there's no way we can do
that
um
and so
until we have to figure out a way that
that is not the method we get that
um we probably will not adjust it
um but you know if all of a sudden the
next what is it uh 40 what you know 38
states that want to work with us tell us
we refuse to do this then we'd be forced
to kind of think of something
differently
um I am looking at the chat now
is there any third-party data so there
is third-party data but we received the
third party data from the state so our
DSA is with the state so the state
excuse me the state will send us
um tables within their their data
warehouse or you know wherever they keep
it
um but some of their data for example
like assessments for example is much
more often collected via a third party
the state actually receives that data
from the third party who will
um and you know upload it ingest it to
their warehouse and then they will have
that table in theirs and then that that
is the table they send to us so it's
always through the state because we have
the agreement with the state to receive
the data
um
okay I think that's all if any point you
want to ask me questions do let me know
I'm happy to answer as we go
um Okay so we've received data from the
state
and then this is where to you know an
amazing Point that's brought up is like
what if the state sends you data and
it's not formatted how we expect the
short answer is it will not be it for it
formatted how we expect every state does
this differently every state thinks of
movements or tables Etc very differently
and so what we do is we build out ingest
views which are SQL queries that pull in
the data from any number of tables that
the state has sent us and then output
how we anticipate a raw data field to
map into our schema as well as well as
it can be mapped and so
um for example I said you know for State
person
um there will be an entity for or there
will be a field for full name and so we
will select from the table that we think
has that information in in using SQL uh
the first name last name birth date and
then or whatever that is and then we
will actually output it as a table from
that SQL query sometimes our SQL queries
our Industries are very simple sometimes
they are
very very very complex
um they can be very heavy depending on
what we have to do how we have to join
the data how many tables need to be
joined in particular for incarceration
periods or supervision periods those
views tend to be very very complex
you're joining
seven to ten different raw data tables
to understand custody Level facility
admission reason release reason state
Authority
many different things so
um some capacity of being able to
discern the easiest way is necessary but
sometimes it is truly just a very gnarly
query that we have to join tables
together
once we have the output from that ingest
view that SQL query we then have
essentially a list of columns that we
have these are the oops these are the
outputs that you'll see these input
columns those are the outputs of the
ingest view query
and then those input columns are what we
use to actually map the field into the
entity so actually into our schema and
so we use yaml mappings this is an
example of a yaml mapping where here's
all the input columns these are the
columns that we created with our ingest
View
and then for State person external ID
we're going to use their client ID for
the birth date we're using the birth
date field from an ingest view query
Etc so
this is basically saying we had all this
raw data it's very chaotic we wrote a
SQL query on top of it to make it
cleaner then we're going to basically
draw lines from each output of the SQL
query into a specific part of our schema
and so this is going to hydrate the
state person object with things like
birth date full name gender
Etc
okay
now we've hydrated our schema for the
you know currently our example is we're
using State person we wrote a SQL query
we mapped that SQL query to where it
should actually exist for all of our
different entities
that process
of um the entities that exist actually
exists in postgres is through a process
called extracted merge that we will
basically say when we first understood
this person's name it was this if we get
new data we can add it in to that same
uh table and if it's the exact same we
don't have to update the entity if
something has changed we could update
the entity in place
which is great news because as you can
imagine things change as data we receive
from a state sometimes they send us the
information like this and then over time
something changes or we get new data and
so we eventually have
um all of that data into what we call
the state table and then the state table
is loaded into bigquery where in
bigquery it can be used to funnel or to
hydrate and funnel all of the downstream
views
from State there's one more thing we can
do so up to this point the way we've
been able to kind of wrangle the data is
we had the raw data we wrote a SQL query
perhaps we did a really complex SQL
query where we hard-coded in some some
things when we saw edge cases or we
figured out a way to account for certain
scenarios like this
but there are other things that
occasionally require additional
processing that frankly are just not
easy to do in SQL or we can't do them
with only looking at a single entity so
one thing to account for is that when we
are looking at an ingest view we are
only hydrating a single entity
but maybe someone's incarceration
um period is influenced by some
information from their incarceration
sentence or vice versa and so we have
one more piece in this ingest pipeline
that we can use to compare entities for
a single person and clean things up and
so that's called normalization
um this happens in data flow and
basically all of the things that got
loaded into state will go through the
normalization pipelines to be cleaned or
changed or adjusted and then
um the output of that is normalized
state
and the output is what's actually used
to funnel all the different calculation
metrics
um a really common thing for example is
perhaps we see someone
they have a violation and we see that
they have a violation we ingest it into
a supervision violation for them but
then we're like okay
we actually realized that the type of
this violation was a technical violation
but we only know that because of their
incarceration period information so we
only know that because of the admission
reason on the incarceration period was a
technical violation and so we didn't get
that from the violations data we can use
normalization to combine those together
to then for the actual entity change it
so the violation type is a technical
violation
okay
obviously this is a pretty heavy kind of
ridiculous process we go through
um the highest level version of like
okay what did I just tell you what is
all this stuff is basically for these
four steps import transform load and
normalize
most of it actually lives in bigquery we
use other platforms to help us with the
process but primarily if you were saying
like how did data move through our data
pipeline
you would see in our bigquery
uh raw data tables so for example you'd
see um
whatever Missouri raw data tables that
are imported
then you would see Missouri industry
results for certain ingest views like
State person
if you went to the state data table you
could query that data table and see all
of the results with a state code of
Missouri that have information on the
people
um in the data for Missouri and then
normalized state would be all of the
data that existed in state cleaned up a
little bit more in case there was
something else that we were missing
so coming back to this kind of scary
graph now we've actually gone through
the process as I mentioned the import is
how we're actually getting all of the
data from the state importing that raw
data ingest is the ingest views the
mappings the normalization all of that
is meant to essentially
streamline the data make it match with
our schema and then normalize it in some
way so that it's as clean as possible
and uh that all of that data then
funnels into this next step which we
call calculate now we do not have enough
time for me to go into the details of
calculate it is even more insane than
what we just went through but as I
mentioned
um
excuse me the
entities the data that comes from
normalize will be used to count various
different metrics they'll be used to
export them into tools
we also have
um a secondary system called sessions
and sessions essentially will help with
um
understanding spans of time that someone
said like overall incarcerated overall
in supervision
all this to say this portion of
calculate
that fuels our products and Analysis is
really what gets us from okay we were
able to identify all the data into a
state to then actually generate metrics
that are interesting and valuable and
important for states to understand how
that's working out
um
that is all the slides I have I'm happy
to answer any and all questions
um the one final thing I will note is
um overall the thing that we hear the
most about from States the thing that
they're most excited about is this
process of ingest that we have
um the way that we have managed to
create a platform that can do it in a
state agnostic way
um and we do have an entire team of
Engineers who are focused on basically
creating all of this and funneling the
data through this pipeline but the way
that we have done this has allowed for
um quite a bit of impact and also just
understanding of the data that does not
exist within States right now
um their ability to stitch together
someone's entire overview of their time
in the system is
um greatly aided by this sort of State
schema overlooking
um
overlooking View
and yeah I'm happy to answer any
questions
uh Genevieve this is Mark I was
wondering you've told us about Pro
postgres and big and bigquery and
was wondering
maybe what other databases were might
have might have been involved if there's
any graph databases what languages you
use to do some processing
um somebody takes the yaml files you
know ingest them and and you know
generates the queries based upon the
ammo files that kind of thing
yeah so we've really used SQL and python
um we really only use uh bigquery and
then postgres is only used for our
extract and merge process between
hydrate and load so that's what allows
us to essentially track how entities
stay the same or change over time
but other than that it is all loaded
into
um Google cloud service Google Cloud
Storage which is then
um
processed via data flow metric so
dataflow is our actual pipelines that
tell us all the logic of how to combine
all this data and then output into data
sets that are used to fuel all of that
we also have visualization tool we use
the looker as a visualization tool so if
we wanted to kind of visualize all this
together we can go to looker and Stitch
together all the different data sets but
um yeah we primarily truly just use
um Google
people and then postgres is simply only
currently for the extracted merge
process
I I've had a comment in the in the chat
and there's there's a question about you
know
ETL versus elt and I said well you're
you're missing an OB an obvious third
third option which is
etlt which is you do part of the
transformation during the the ingesting
process but it before the load process
and then you do other Transformations
after the load process and I think what
you're doing is a good illustration of
that
yeah definitely
um this has yeah worth calling out like
this what is currently our ingest
pipeline today has gone through a number
of iterations and it's specifically born
out of you know what you're mentioning
kind of the discussion around like what
is actually most useful how are we
actually able to
clean the data in the way that keeps
everyone who's working on it sane enough
and also
um
can do it in a way that is correct
um we have had to more or lesser extent
some states that work with us just say
great and clean the data incredible but
we also have had states that said wait
this process that you're doing can you
let us know what
[Music]
things you have to account for in your
transformation or normalization process
because that's something that we would
love to know that's like not being
perhaps done correctly or is you know an
interesting way to do it um
and so we've had states that are
actually quite interested in like what
are you doing to get to the point after
normalization and what actual logic are
you applying because that is indicative
to us of
um kind of like what is necessary for
our data so
it has been iterated on and this is
currently the iteration because it by
far in a way gives us the best results
over time
any other questions
Genevieve I'm curious I think one of the
biggest challenges of creating a
standardized view of data is that
someone is going to have something that
you didn't anticipate and you'll
find or think that it might be very
valuable have you seen that happen and
do you have a way to kind of add in
flexibility for
whether it's just a flexible field where
you can capture something new or or you
maybe update your schemas over time
great question
um we certainly update our schema we
have an entire process called schema
change request that essentially means
that as we learn more about how
how we interpret the data how States
interpret the data you know informs
perhaps we need a new field here or
perhaps we need to change this or
perhaps we need to add certain enums to
this like all of that happens very much
so and it is very much like a live and
living schema in that way and it has
gone through several you know major
iterations or overhauls of like do we
actually need this entity should we add
this entity Etc
um and so all the to say like the short
answer is yes we of course do update it
and change it I will say it's constantly
a little bit of a of a kind of push and
pull because the whole point of having
this datagnostic schema is to figure out
a way that
um you know we can make things work and
be able to compare across um different
states like the state agnostic analyzes
we're able to do because we have this
you know one way of looking at things
um are really really powerful and so we
do have somewhat of a high threshold for
when we would drastically change schema
um one thing that's also important to
note is like for example
we will hydrate all the key entities
within a state in the state agnostic way
and sometimes for a specific opportunity
within a state they'll need this random
piece of information that doesn't like
exist in our schema and shouldn't like
it's not relevant for us to have and so
we do have an ability within our
products and our analyzes that our
analysts can pull in raw data so
basically I is implementation engineer
can get the raw data and put it into our
system and it will live in bigquery as
the raw data and a data analyst can
incorporate that Downstream as something
that's like viewable in a product first
for whatever reason or something that's
used as a certain Dimension with an
analysis we admittedly try not to do
that
as often as possible because using raw
data is kind of the whole reason we made
this whole process it's like there's you
know weird character like all this whole
process in terms that we don't have for
your characters and we don't have weird
data anomalies and we've actually done
many different validation tests to go
through it
um but we do certainly have situations
where we have to pull that in in
different ways and be creative about it
so the classic saying that my team would
be you know making fun of me for
bringing this up because I literally
always say it is that the process of
ingest is really an art not a science
like it is very much weaving together
in the most creative way we can
things the way that things move forward
and so um we
you know on a case-by-case basis make
judgment calls based on how things can
work as cleanly as possible but
sometimes that just means we end up
doing some things a little bit
differently
um when you say normalize and do you
have to go are you
are you talking about database
normalization first normal form second
normal form or is this something or is
this something that's
that's
less with the structure and relationship
of data and more uh you know
this this data has to has to look this
this particular way because XYZ rules
are in existence
yeah it's more of the second it's it's
more referring to specifically
biblical State table and the norm
same structure we do add a couple fields
in normalization but the overall
structure is the same and truly it is
just more of what you're referring to
the second which is just that there are
certain
rules like for example one of the things
that we do in normalization
is if we have a noted death date for
someone but the raw data indicates them
being incarcerated after that
our normalization has a has a method
that will truncate all periods as of the
death date of someone and so there's
things like that that it's basically
just like certain rules we know have to
be true in in practice like in real life
that
because of the way that data is
documented within States it's just
typically not you know that's not
necessarily a check that they're doing
they're not necessarily building in
rules to their database that's requiring
that and so we build in certain things
that make it so that we don't have
strange data anomalies that would be
discovered later on
um down our pipeline when we're
servicing individuals for opportunities
and things like that
um I do see a question here on half date
switched over to your database after
seeing how data can be updated to newer
software
um definitely not
um
so states are very excited about the
work we can do and are always eager to
learn about our platform and the process
we're doing here
um but for obvious reasons we are able
to do that because of
our structure as an organization
um obviously most of the states are
using their state government databases
and and it's a much bigger bigger bigger
system um it's not necessarily only the
doc that's using these databases it's
every state agency
um and so all that to say I think
in the long term of course government
data wants to up upgrade and update
things but it has to be by definition a
slow process and it should be because
they are dealing with many many many
many many other factors that we do not
have to account for
um but they are certainly excited when
they see it and excited to know that
this could be done and transparently
um depending on the state we're working
with certain states are further along in
this kind of data transformation space
than others certain states are you know
trying to upgrade everything to this and
are automatically excited about this
other states are like you know we've got
a way other different things to worry
about and so we're not worried about
updating our databases anytime soon and
so
um
at some point in the future I imagine
all you know state governments will need
to address in some capacity updating to
newer versions of things but for now
um we receive all of their data as read
only so like we aren't actually able to
update or change anything in their
specific systems
um we basically are just visualizing
things for them in a way that's much
cleaner so that they can actually update
it in their systems themselves
any other questions
[Music]
I was curious what
I was curious sort of what the best or
most memorable results that you've had
so far have been
um
[Music]
we've had a lot of
overall products and analyzes that have
been
rolled out it's hard to pick just one
um for me in particular
um I have worked pretty extensively on
several tools related to
automating the process for getting
people on lower levels of supervision
whether that's through compliant
reporting or through
um
early you know basically they have to
fill out this note that gets them
discharged and previously it would take
like months extra off of their a month
extra after they were eligible to fill
out this note because it simply wasn't
automated and we've automated that form
in a way that people literally get a
notification the second that someone is
eligible and then they can final that
note so I think things like that um feel
very much of a win because it is truly
like processes and policies that are
already on the books just being acted
upon the way they actually can be acted
upon which is really incredible
um we've also more recently gotten more
involved in
facility side
um work and so
um bringing to light various different
um opportunities for someone to receive
hearing re-evaluation after they've been
in restricted housing for a certain
amount of time
um and so we've done a lot of you know
uxr and and Research into ways in which
perhaps restricted housing is not being
used as an as a very effective School
within the facilities
um and for me personally that is is
really intriguing work because it's
um
something that has a really huge impact
on someone's experience Within system
I am going to not say the number because
I don't know the actual most accurate
number today but in particular force one
of the states that we're working with we
launch a number of opportunities and
through all of the opportunities where
we surface people that were eligible for
downgrade or eligible for reduced
supervision sentences or something like
that
um there's something like
20 to 30 percent of their entire
supervision population is eligible for
an opportunity like it's a very high
number don't quote me on that number I
don't know what it is today but I think
pointing that out is really impactful
because it's showing that
what we're doing is difficult work and
working criminal justice is difficult
work but the fact that we are just
basically surfacing something that
should exist already or that could exist
I think is really encouraging to show
that there is so much opportunity for
um impact and so much opportunity to
really improve many different people's
experience in the criminal justice
system so that is certainly what gets me
up in the morning and excited to work on
this especially when there are certain
days when I'm mad about delimiters or
encodings or SQL queries um because the
work is challenging but it is certainly
worth it because we are able to have
really direct impact on people's
experience
any other questions
well thank you to both uh Lily and
Genevieve uh let me share my let me
share my screen for the next
the next little segment